اكد وزراء خارجيه دول التعاون الخليجي
ووزير الخارجيه الامريكي في بيان مشترك
اكد على اهميه جهود خفض التصعيد في
المنطقه والمساهمه في الاستقرار والازدهار
على الصعيد الاقليمي وعبر البيان الخليجي
الامريكي عن الالتزام بالتوصل الى سلام
عادل ودائم وشامل في الشرق الاوسط وفقا
لحل الدولتين ورفض اي اجراءات احاديه
وخاصه في القدس وشدد البيان على ضروره
التزام ايران بالتعاون الكامل مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ورحب باستئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين السعوديه وايران
وبشان السودان اشاد البيان بجهود الرياض و
واشنطن عبر منبر جده للوصول الى اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع مشددا على انه لا حل عسكريا
للازمه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات